Luffy has just found the once piece and
the final war that will determine the
fate of the world is about to begin. The world
government is on the brink of collapse. And in
a last ditch effort to get rid of Luffy,
*they are willing to bet every last piece
of gold they have* to issue the highest
bounties the world has ever seen. But,
how crazy will the straw hats final bounties
at the end of the story actually be?
Starting with the crew’s doctor, Chopper.
It’s a reoccurring joke is the series that
Chopper always has a laughably low bounty. The
marines have always thought that that Chopper,
being a reindeer, is just the Straw Hats’ pet.
First he had a bounty of 50 berries. It then
doubled to 100. And then it multiplied by ten
all the way to the incredible sum of…1,000
berries. However, surely by the end of the
series someone in the government will catch on
to this reindeer’s genius level intellect. Now,
it’s totally possible that we won’t even get any
more bounties. After all, the World Government
might not even exist at the end of the story.
However, in this scenario, let’s just imagine
what they could be if the Straw Hats really do
accomplish their dreams and claim the One Piece.
This amazing doctor has the dream of
curing every disease - and while this
is a very positive thing for the world,
it’s also indispensable for the Straw
Hat crew. Chopper poses a huge risk to the
government because he can heal any injury or
disease that the dangerous Straw Hat pirates
face. And you see, Eiichiro Oda, the author
of One Piece, absolutely loves to use wordplay
with the numbers he uses in his series. Chopper’s
devil fruit, the Hito Hito no Mi or Human Human
fruit can actually be read as “Hi-To” like the
japanese word for the number one ‘hitotsu’ -
Therefore it only makes sense that Chopper’s
final bounty would include “HiTo” in honor of his
devil fruit! That’s why I’m going to multiply his
current bounty by 1000! That will bring him
to 1,000,000 berries but for good measure
I’m going to throw on an extra 100,000. That
bring’s Chopper’s bounty to 1,100,000 berries.
Someday, when the Straw Hats finally reach the One
Piece, they’ll only make it there due to Nami’s
navigation skills. As the Straw Hats’ navigator,
they literally couldn’t get anywhere without
her. The only reason they’re able to brave the
perilous seas of the One Piece world is through
her expert understanding of the weather.Therefore
hugely increasing her current bounty makes sense
due to the danger she presents to the World
Government. As a fighter, Nami is one of the
weakest members of the Straw Hat crew and has
a hard time holding her own against the members
of Yonkou crews. However, after recruiting
Big Mom’s Cloud Homie, Zeus, to her side,
she’s become a more threatening combatant. It
might seem extreme to bring Nami of all people
above 1,000,000,000 berries, but we have to
remember - these are the bounties of the Pirate
King’s crew - and possibly the last bounties
that the government will ever put out.Also,
of course, I expect that her bounty
poster will follow the same pattern as
it has previously. Each time an undercover Marine
photographer will ask for her to pose for photos,
which she’s always more than willing to model
for. Somehow she hasn’t caught on that these
photographers aren’t in it for her good looks, but
that she’s actually posing for the most glamorous
bounty poster on the high seas. Nami’s bounty is
going to raise from 366,000,000 to 1,172,000,000.
Once he leads an army of giants. Usopp will become
a brave warrior of the sea. Once the Straw Hats
sail to Elbaf, he’ll use his connections to
the giants he’s met so far like Kashi, Oimo,
Dorry, and Broggy to forge an alliance and end
up leading a whole army of giants against the
World Government. After feats like this, the World
Government will have no choice but to put a bounty
on Usopp’s head that exceeds one billion berries.
And that will be comedy gold because Usopp is one
Straw Hat that actively wants his bounty to
be lower. Every time he gets a higher bounty,
he freaks out and would very much not like the
World Government to be after him. But despite his
best efforts his feats, whether accidental or not,
keep pushing his bounty higher and higher.After
freeing the Dressrosa prisoners and being
worshipped as God Usopp, he gained a bounty
of 200,000,000 berries. He even had the God
Usopp name put on his wanted poster. After Wano,
he’s considered an important crew member of a
Yonkou crew and raised to 500,000,000 berries.
It’s not out of the ordinary for a Yonkou
crew member to have a bounty of 1 billion
or above. And while Usopp’s strength, at least
right now doesn’t justify this high of a number,
the government won’t know how weak Usopp actually
is in a head to head fight. They’ll just know that
he has an army of giants at his disposal. And
who knows, maybe the theory that Usopp will
awaken conqueror’s haki, will actually turn out
to be true as well. So by the end of the story,
I want Usopp to have a bounty of
1,100,000,000. But wow - if Usopp’s
bounty is over a billion…just imagine how
high Luffy’s will be by the end of the series.
I’m surprised that Brook’s bounty
poster says “Dead or Alive”...since he’s
already dead. [Brook Laugh Here]
But we’re not talking about that
part of the wanted poster. We’re
here to talk about that bounty.
Already in the story, Brook, the ship’s musician,
is one of the biggest celebrities in the One Piece
world. The rock star Soul King Brook is loved
by music fans all across the oceans. And how
will it make the Straw Hats look once people find
out their favorite rock star is a member of the
crew? People all over will have a favorable
view of the Straw Hats, which means Brook is
a big threat to people’s willingness to go
along with the World Government’s wishes.
In addition, Brook is a powerful fighter on the
Straw Hat crew and was even able to survive a solo
battle against Big Mom. While he was obviously
defeated due to her overwhelming strength,
the fact that he was even able to land a scratch
on one of her homies is a testament to his power.
One day, the World Government will likely
realize how strong Brook actually is. And
this isn’t even mentioning his stealth
abilities. If it ever becomes common
knowledge that Brook can use his spirit form
to spy on enemies without being noticed,
his danger to the government
will be considered even higher.
All of these reasons come together to make
his final bounty 1,430,000,000. Why 430
million? Well because Brook’s devil fruit, the
yomi-yomi no mi can also be read as “Yo-Mi” or
“4-3”. Therefore, it’s only right that
“43” appears in his bounty somewhere.
Cyborg Franky, the shipwright of the Straw
Hats,has finally met his inventor idol: Dr.
Vegapunk. And by the end of the story, he’ll learn
from Vegapunk’s technology. To be specific - there
is a 99.9% chance we’re going to see Franky
pilot a giant mech against the World Government.
And even without a giant mech, Franky is
one of the strongest fighters on the crew.
Already existing Franky inventions like
General Franky are also powerful enough
to fight SUPER strong pirates - earning him
his current bounty of 394,000,000. After all,
he deserves a huge bounty after he
motorcycled Big Mom right in the face.
And after all, in the same way that Nami is
invaluable to the crew due to her navigation
skills, the Straw Hats wouldn’t be able to make
their voyage without their ship, the Thousand
Sunny. Franky built it and is constantly repairing
its damage as well as giving it powerful upgrades.
We saw how hard the World Government came down on
Tom, the shipwright for Roger’s ship. Imagine how
severely he’d been punished if he was actually
Roger’s crew mate. That in itself is worthy
of a huge bounty. So by the end of the story,
he’ll have a bounty of 1,832,000,000 berries.
Jinbe, the Knight of the Sea, the former captain
of the Sun Pirates, and a former Shichibukai. But
despite all of his former titles, Jinbe is now
first and foremost the helmsman of the Straw Hat
Pirates. The World Government needs to be prepared
to defend themselves at sea because in the final
war they’ll have to deal with legions of fishmen
and sea kings being led by Jinbe. After Wano,
Jinbe already has a billion berry bounty. Since
he’s already over a billion, there’s only one way
to go: up. He is undoubtedly one of the fiercest
fighters on the Straw Hat crew. As a fishman,
he’s unstoppable in the ocean, with the
ability to take out entire ships with one
attack from his fishman karate. He’s also a
great leader and strategist who can step in
when Luffy is otherwise occupied. After all,
he was already the leader of another famous
and powerful pirate crew. His desire for fishman
liberation stands opposed to the World Government,
making him a huge threat to their established
order. And so as one of the strongest crew
members and one of the most respected
individuals across the One Piece world,
Jinbe will receive a bounty of
2,500,000,000 by the end of the story.
Robin isn’t as powerful as Jinbe, but
she poses the biggest threat to the
World Government out of all the crew with
the possible exception of Luffy. Once she
uncovers the true history of the world one of
the only people who can read the poneglyphs,
the government will be even more desperate
to capture her. After all, revealing this
truth to the world will probably cause a
worldwide revolution. If knowledge is power,
Robin is one of the most powerful characters
in One Piece. She’s also the Straw Hats’ direct
connection to the Revolutionary Army, having spent
the time skip with them. She’s directly worked
with Monkey D. Dragon and Sabo, probably being
even closer to them than Luffy is even though
Luffy is Dragon’s actual son. It’s certain that
when it’s time to topple the World Government,
Robin will be one person who’s leading the
charge. After all, the revolutionaries were
inspired to form after the destruction of
Ohara, of which Robin is the last survivor.
While with the revolutionaries, she also received
plenty of combat training. Even though she’s not
as strong as the premiere fighters of the
crew, she can definitely hold her own,
having defeated Black Maria, one of
Kaidou’s Flying Six. The government
knows exactly how much of a threat Robin
actually is, having tried to capture
her all of her life - that’s why the Devil
Child will earn a 2,870,000,000 berry bounty.
Sanji is one of the wings of the pirate king. He’s
one of the Straw Hat crew’s strongest members,
able to fight toe-to-toe literally with Yonkou
commanders like Kaidou’s third in command,
Queen. After Wano, he’s unlocked power
ups from his latent Germa powers,
activated by his raid suit that have made him
an even more powerful combatant. While other
crew members excel in fighting directly, in the
final war Sanji is sure to use his other skill
set. Sanji is a master of strategy and stealth
and certainly we’ll see Mr. Prince again by the
end of One Piece. Mr. Prince is the secret
identity that Sanji uses for spycraft - and
using his intellect he was able to foil the
plans of cunning characters like Crocodile.
He’s already used these skills against the
World Government when he allowed the crew
to escape Enies Lobby by opening the gates of
justice, and we’re sure to see them again.Sanji,
like Robin, spells trouble for the World
Government. As a prince of the Germa Kingdom,
he’s the only character we’ve ever seen
with an Only Alive bounty poster. As a
member of one of the 40 kingdoms that form
the World Government, he poses a huge threat,
and after the events of Whole Cake Island will
likely be able to rally all of the forces of Germa
66 against the government in the final war. His
current bounty is over a billion, but I predict
that by the end of the story, he’ll achieve a
bounty of 3,000,000,000 berries - equivalent to
Luffy’s current bounty. The “san” in “Sanji”
is the Japanese word for “three” after all,
so it only makes sense that it would be included
in his final bounty. If Sanji will catch up to
Luffy’s already huge bounty, though - what does
that say about how ridiculous Luffy’s will become?
By the time of the final war, Zoro won’t just
be the right hand man of the pirate king - he’ll
be the world’s greatest swordsman and one
of the strongest characters in the verse.
After he finally defeats Dracule Mihawk, there
will be no question of Zoro’s immense power.
By the end, Zoro’s sure to upgrade his swords to
have at least one supreme grade blade. In
addition, since he has conqueror’s haki,
he’s almost certain to infuse his
swords with haki to create black blades.
For this reason, the Marines will issue
a bounty of at least 3,000,000,001. Yes.
This number is a single berry above Sanji’s
bounty. And nothing would make Sanji more
furious than having his final bounty be
lower than Zoro’s - even if it’s only by
one. This would be a top tier joke from Oda
, and we don’t think he’s one to pass up such
a comedic moment. Zoro and Sanji have always
been at each other’s throats, but all in all,
Zoro deserves the higher bounty even if just
by a little bit. He’s been with Luffy from the
start of the adventure and has been willing
to sacrifice everything for his captain.
Luffy will follow in his father’s
footsteps and become the most wanted
man in the world. He’ll also take after
the former pirate king, Gol D. Roger,
and earn the highest bounty the
World Government has ever issued.
Why? He’s the man who attacked Enies
Lobby. He’s the man who coordinated
the largest prison break in Impel Down’s
history. He joined Whitebeard’s assault on
Marineford. He’s an Emperor of the Sea,
having taken down Kaidou. And he’s the
inheritor of the Nika fruit - the next
Joyboy - and the Warrior of Liberation.
When Luffy brings the dawn of the world, he
will very likely risk toppling the world’s
powers - destroying Mariejois and ending the
Celestial Dragons’ rule. For all of this and more,
we’re tempted to give him the highest
bounty ever at just above Roger. Roger’s
bounty was 5.5 billion, so Luffy’s could
suitably be 5.6 billion berries. After all,
56 is often associated Luffy because it works
with Japanese wordplay for “Go-Mu” or “5-6.”
However, we all know that Luffy doesn’t have
the Gomu Gomu no Mi. There’s no such fruit.
Like Chopper, he has a model of the Hito Hito no
Mi - the Human Human Fruit Model Nika. And like
we discussed earlier, the wordplay for “Hi-To”
is “1”. Hito hito- so 11. We’re having fun here
so let’s predict an absolutely absurd bounty for
Luffy. I want to see Luffy being the first person
ever to cross a 10 Billion bounty, so that
the Marines have to put every last piece of
gold they have on the table. So, by the end of the
series Luffy will have a bounty of 11,565,600,000.
That would give Luffy the highest bounty of
all time, but it’s still just an educated
guess. If you want to see the newly updated
21 official highest bounties in One Piece,
you can watch that video right here.
thanks so much for hanging out with me
today. if you had fun or learned anything
do me a favor like subscribe comment share
— I know it's annoying to hear me ask that
but it really helps out the channel and like
most topics we cover on this channel today's
topic was recommended by you. if there's a
topic you'd like to see or learn more about,
just leave me a comment under this video. Thanks.